en el pequeño pueblo de bellow Diez mil
habitantes todos se conocen todos saben
quién viven qué casa Quién es familia de
quién y desde el terremoto del lunes
quien ha muerto y quién no Asís un
vecino del lugar cree que el número de
fallecidos se acerca a los 300 lo sabe
también porque él rescató a algunos de
sus vecinos aquí no ha venido ningún
Equipo de rescate
yo saqué a dos personas les había caído
su edificio encima y solo los
conseguimos sacar después de que
fallecieran yo no sé aquí a nadie con
vida pero otros vecinos sí que
consiguieron hacerlo aquí y en otros
pueblos todos intentaron hacerlos con
sus propios recursos la ayuda sin
embargo sí que ha llegado pero tarde los
vecinos del lugar han recibido comida y
agua pero necesitan Con urgencia
productos sanitarios
pero sobre todo tiendas de campaña la
mayoría de los habitantes de bellow
duerme a la intemperie congelándose a
varios grados bajo cero esta familia por
suerte tenía en su casa plásticos y
telas halil el padre consiguió de todo
ello crear un lugar donde dormir en su
propio jardín
unos kilómetros más al sur el pueblo de
chequerova y su cementerio Las lápidas
nuevas las frescas las improvisadas
superan a las antiguas hussein cuya casa
queda cerca intenta ayudar a las
familias que lloran a sus seres queridos
las familias como pueden traen sus
fallecidos el cementerio ellos mismos
los entierran esta noche ha habido dos
entierros en uno de ellos había tres
fallecidos eran una madre y sus dos
hijos que fueron encontrados muertos
mientras estaban abrazados sus cuerpos
estaban Unidos había mucho olor
según Justin Ese es el primer día desde
el terremoto que el cementerio está
tranquilo Las lápidas no todas tienen
marcados algunos nombres tuba Cádiz
zeynep sus apellidos sus historias son
desconocidas
para el mundo serán un número que se
sumará a otras decenas de miles para sus
familias un punto y final